e
[Music]
CHR sh
it's
yeah really
[Music]
test T there we go I always and forever
want to say good morning good morning
everyone I just I'm all so used to
church in the morning it's just going to
be ingrained in me forever so my name is
Mariam for those of you all that I have
not met for everyone else I have met
nice to see you all pronouns are she her
want to welcome you um and also our
guest visitors online I'm looking for a
camera I don't know where they are but
welcome to y'all as well um as always we
love having everyone here and it's
cooling down a little bit outside that's
kind of nice right a little bit little
bit I think it's cooling down I I think
it feels nice all right couple of
announcements for us so our first Sunday
Community me meal will be the first
Sunday in August there's a QR code up on
the screen or you can also um join the
at theable Facebook group side note if
you're not in that group already I
highly recommend you do so there's a lot
of good info that comes out of that
either way either scan that code or on
that Facebook group you will find a sign
up link if you wanted to go to that um
join that potluck meal it's going to be
potluck I don't think I said that and
sign up for a meal to share and bring
with
everyone as we've said you know every
other week in July and weeks leading up
to it July is our kind of our rest
downtime month and what that means is
once a year we take a month and we have
people like our Meetup leaders um not
have any groups or just take some
downtime and rest but for the most part
you'll notice that we don't have kind of
our leading staff here so namely Mindy
Maggie Brett um it's a time for them to
kind of rejuvenate take some time off to
for themselves gear up and be ready to
come back in August with that being said
we do have the wonderful Jesse and Josh
yes that's his dad not my dad that's my
friend leading worship tonight and then
we also have Pastor Holly I heard you
introduce your name to someone I'm sorry
I didn't get to introduce my out to you
um leading us through the sermon tonight
so make sure um you give them a warm
welcome and
such um as you are able and willing feel
free to stand so we can kind of gear
into getting into
worship let's go ahead and Center
ourselves quiet all that noise that's
around us everything you came in with
previous
week and let these words flow over you
as we get into worship
now we exit the kingdom of noise hurry
and
productivity now we enter the kingdom
kingdom of Silence Stillness and
simplicity Sacred Space a place for a
space for prayer worship and
adoration a space to behold
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation
allow The unforced rhythms of Grace to
find you to mend your heart may we all
come home
[Music]
if you're lost and you're
lonely go and figure out
why take a trip to your dark side go on
and have a good
cry cuz we're all
lonely yes we're all
lonely to
together I want to see your
sadness I want to see your sins I want
to bleed your blood and I want to be let
in don't you just don't we all just want
to be
together sing this together
[Music]
leave what's
heavy what's heavy
behind
leave what's
heavy what's heavy behind
[Music]
if your face is
down take a look
[Music]
around do your fingers move do your LS
inflate are you tired are you we of the
Hidden hate you've been
holding
hey did you lose that love or have you
never had it are you feeling sad because
you did a bad thing
[Music]
leave what's
heavy what's heavy
behind
leave what's
[Music]
heavy what's heavy behind
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful
sister only way to lose that fearful
feeling replace it with love that's
healing
[Music]
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful
[Applause]
sister what's
heavy what's heavy
behind
the what heavy
what's heavy
behind just your
voices what
[Music]
heavy what heavy
behind
leave what's
heavy what heavy heav
[Music]
behind yes the kiddos you are dismissed
follow your teachers
please adults you are not dismissed
yet some of you were thinking about it I
know you
were uh right now as as they are kind of
exiting the space we are going to head
into our prayers of the people um and if
you are not familiar with this this is
just a time where we open up some space
after we prayer uh pray a prayer
together we open up some space where we
can say the names of people we're
praying for or you can stay silent but
it's just to hold hold some space for
everything that we're carrying for
ourselves for others so we're going to
uh I'll read this the leader part and
then you will read the the part that
says
all for this city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
in my mother's
WB you formed me with your hands known
in Love by
you before I took a breath when when I
doubt it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist and a
part I'm the canvas and the
clay and you make all
things work
together for my future
and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your
[Music]
name yes
there's a healing
light just beyond the clouds though I've
walked through
fire I see clearly now I know nothing
has been
wasted no failure or mistake you in an
artist and a party I'm the canvas and
the
clay you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work together
For Your
Glory and for your
name your
name and when I doubt it Lord remind me
I'm
wonderfully made you in artist and a
part I'm the cist and the clay and I
know nothing has been
wasted no failure or mistake you're in
arst and aart I'm the cist and the clay
and when I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're in an artist
stand a part from the canas and the clay
and I know nothing has been wasted no
failure or mistake you're in arst Stand
aart I'm the C and the clay
[Music]
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me yet you're not finished
with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
you're not finished with me no you're
not finished with with me you make all
things work
together for my
[Music]
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name when I I doubt
it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're in arst and a
part the C and the clay and I know
nothing has been
wasted no failure or
mistake you're an artist and a part of
the C and the clay
[Music]
Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I stand
when everything around me is
shaken I've never been more glad that I
put my faith in
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful through
generations so why would he fail
now he
won't no he won't no he
won't I've still got joy in
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going under
I'm not held by My Own Strength cuz I
build my life on
Jesus cuz he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fail
now he
won't no he won't no
[Music]
W he won't
fail he won't
fail he
won't he
won he won't
fail he won't fail
Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I stand and
everything around me is
shaken I've never been more glad I put
my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he faithful
through
[Music]
generations so why would he fa
now he
won't he
won't he won't
fail he won't fail
he
[Music]
W when came away wind
blew my house was built
on and now safe with you I'm going to
make it
through rain came Wind Through My House
was built on
you I'm safe
with you I'm going to make it
through and I'm going to make it
through cuz I'm standing strong on
you and I'm going to make it
through my house was built on
you and I'm going to make it through
cuz my standing strong on
you and I'm going to make it
[Music]
through cuz my house was built on
you make it
[Music]
Jesus nothing feels like standing on a
rock right
now Everything feels like it's on top of
weird Shifty sand that we can't really
get a
foothold Lord our faith is in you
who is the firm rock beneath our
feet the place where we build our
lives our
[Music]
homes mysterious
Christ we open our lives open ourselves
to
you Lord I pray that our ears would be
open that our hearts would be softened
to what we're going to hear
tonight I ask this in your
name
amen why don't you turn around to people
say hello give a compliment or an
awkward smile whatever feels
right we good
Jesse and Josh I always feel more
centered more
grounded more calm after we all sing
together so thank you Jesse and Josh for
the work that you guys do to make that
available to us as a community it is
always
appreciated uh my name is Karen Miner
I'm one of the founding members here at
the table and it is good to see your
faces tonight and uh wel welcome to
those watching online as well I get the
privilege to announce our guest speaker
and this person is extra special because
our church would literally not be
meeting in this space if it wasn't for
her and her congregation saying yes to
us and I didn't anticipate getting
emotional when I said that that is rare
for churches like us to get the kind of
hospitality and generosity that h
and Saxy first has extended to us and I
just want us to sit with up for a moment
like what a what a gift what a big deal
what an act of Love um and so we get to
hear from Pastor Holly tonight which is
wonderful she is the pastor of Saxy
first and as we already know even even
if you haven't met Pastor Holly you know
something about her you know that she
has a heart for serving a heart for the
Lord a heart of generosity and
Hospitality um and her community is like
that too I walk in every week and see a
new service project or a garden project
or Outreach that's happening and I love
when we get these opportunities
to see with our own eyes the kingdom of
God and not be in a silo that can
sometimes happen with church especially
on Sundays we're here we're in the walls
of a building but today and like we've
done with our our other guest speakers
we get a chance to widen our perspective
to hear from others to expand the
kingdom um so it is my pleasure to
welcome Pastor Holly bandal would you
help me welcome her up here we'll
[Applause]
hear thank you so
much it has been awesome to work with
your team here today
um and um I'm Holly my pron names are
she her and um I've been a pastor for 24
years I was 13 when I started no I'm
just kidding um and um I've been at this
church first year I'm at this church
saxi since August of last year and um
that's when I met um Brett and started
talking about the table church it was
about the time when the leadership team
was y'all were trying to figure out what
to do running out of space at your
former site and um I was new and I was
meeting Brett and we really hit it off
and our teams kind of hit it off and we
just it really was a
partnership um that just came together
and I call that God and so I am grateful
I believe that in our partnership um we
grow stronger as Faith communities and
so I am just grateful to be here and get
to know you and you may see me
occasionally I'm here we've we have
Bible study at 6 so sometimes I slip in
because I love the music of course I
love Pastor Brett but I also love the
prayers of the people and the way you
all do that with telling the team that's
that's one of my favorite parts and so
um tonight I want to share with you a
message it's called
stay in love with God and this um
message came from a series that I did
recently with our
congregation um and a little bit of
Methodist background okay so um um uni
meth methodism was started by John Wes
Wesley who's the founder of the
Methodist movement and he was an
Anglican priest um in the
1700s and um one of the things that he
he was a revivalist
and so um we really kind of in the
Methodist tradition um take parts from
kind of a a Catholic traditional way of
understanding and also this revivalist
nature of evangelism and reaching out in
the community and the world and so um
one of the things that John Wesley did
pretty quickly is what what our faith
communties do is that we said hey you
know it's real hard to learn in a big
group all the time so you need to have
smaller groups where you um have some
accountability and support and all of
that and so that's one of the first
things that John Wesley did um he called
them like the holy club which isn't very
cool but maybe it was in the 1700s I
don't know but anyway so he had these
groups as people began to understand
kind of what he was preaching um
intentionally and uh and those um groups
were given three rules okay they're not
like the rules the teacher puts up on
the wall okay but three kind of
spiritual rules to live by and those
worldes were Do no harm sounds familiar
right lots of people take the oath to do
no harm right do
good and stay in love with God and so
we're going to talk about the third of
those um this
evening let's pray God I'm grateful to
be in this
place and I am in awe of the way that
you bind us
together as we follow the
Christ and I pray that this time might
be a time where we know your deep love
and compassion for us
always and through the Holy Spirit
experience that compassion and grace and
mercy Mercy in real
ways and that this might be a message
for each of us to know you more deeply
and to follow you in Jesus name we
pray
amen the Lord is my
shepherd I shall not
want he makes me to lie down in Green
Pastures he leads me beside The Still
Waters he restores my
soul he leads me in Paths of
righteousness for his name's sake even
though I walk through the darkest
Valley I fear no
evil for you are with me your rod and
your
staff they comfort
me those are the words of Psalm 23
I learned those words of the Bible as a
child um some of you may be familiar
with them they're often read at times of
death and graveside and things like that
um ultimately I find these words the
Lord is my
shepherd I shall not want I find a sense
of
trust in that and comfort
and yet I know how hard trust and
comfort in God is to come
by the person who wrote this Psalm maybe
King
David obviously understood the ups and
downs of real life of the spiritual life
that life e and flows it's stressful and
we we have times that are tragic and
hard and we also have times in which we
do feel comfort and peace and like we're
being carried and guided by a
Shepherd so this isn't the only time
that a Shepherd is used in the Bible if
you know the Christmas story of course
there were shepherds there that they
were kind of dirty and messy
we also see an image of the Shepherd in
Mark chapter 6 and that's where I'd like
to
focus for a few minutes in Mark chapter
6 we see that Jesus has sent his
disciples away on a mission he's kind of
taught them and he sent them out to do
the work that he's called them to do in
Ministry
and so they go and they do Jesus tells
them to do they teach and they heal and
and uh on verse 30 of chapter 6 of Mark
they come back and they gather around
Jesus and this is what it says the
apostles gathered around Jesus and told
him all they had done and taught and he
said to them come away to a deserted
place all by
yourselves and rest a while for many
were coming and going and they had no
leisure even to
eat and they went away in the boat to a
deserted place by themselves now many
saw them going and recognized them and
they hurried there on foot from all the
towns and arrived ahead of them and as
Jesus went
ashore he saw a great
crowd and he had compassion for them
because they were like
sheep without a
shepherd and he began to teach them many
things you know Jesus has compassion on
this crowd I would have not been so
generous I mean when I'm going to a
place to get away and rest and then
there's a great crowd I'm like no no no
no no turn off the messages right like
we're we're not doing that anymore but
it says that Jesus has compassion for
them because they were like sheep
without a
shepherd and so the implication in the
scripture is Jesus is that compassionate
Shepherd for the
people so what is this compassion that
Jesus experiences as a Shepherd so I
looked up compassion simple definition
is sympathetic
pity and concern for the s sufferings or
misfortunes of others you know I think
that's a good definition but it seems a
bit kind of like surface level to me and
it seems like the The Compassion that
Jesus is experiencing is a little bit
deeper so I looked it up and there's a
commentator Karen Marie eust and she
says this about the compassion Jesus
experien of Jesus experience and she he
says this this compassion really means
suffering with the one who suffers
suffering with the one who suffers and
there's a Greek verb for compassion that
I can't pronounce but when you get to
that root of that Greek word for
compassion that's used here it's the
root word for
intestines I'm like what can't make this
stuff up
right compassion she says is something
you feel in your
gut compassion is what bubbles up in us
when we see someone else experiencing
pain a pain that we have experienced and
know all too well we internalize that
pain in the core of our very being
well that says to me is that in order
for Jesus to experience compassion he
had to understand suffering this is
before the cross
right we know Jesus experienced
suffering on the cross but this is
before the cross and we're getting in
touch with jesus' experience of
compassion and it means understanding
the suffering of
people so compassion is a human
experience in fact we're learning that
just now you know there all kind kind of
studies now on compassion um Stanford
University has a whole Center for
compassion and altruism research and
what they're finding is that we are
Wired from
compassion and kindness just like Jesus
exhibits and
yet all our human stuff gets in the way
right stress busyness grief
the way we treat people fear all of that
gets in the way of us really
understanding that natural sensation in
our very
being as
compassion and this is where I think
stay in love with God comes into view
for
us I believe staying in love with God is
about receiving compassion
as well as giving
compassion you know when John Wesley the
founder of Methodist movement talked
about this rule he said it was tending
to the ordinances of God it doesn't
really roll off the tongue right so we
just say stay in love with God tending
to the ordinances of God and what that
means is that there are ways that we can
stay in love with God there there are
things practices that we can do that
really help us to stay and keep God's
compassion and love and Mercy at the
Forefront of our
lives so then J John Wesley in good
perfectionist fashion as he was gives us
a list of things that help us to stay in
love with God worship of
God
check right um the ministry of the word
preaching of course he was a preacher he
would say that
right communion or the supper of the
Lord Prayer scripture
fasting these are some primary
ways that we continually realize God's
compassion and care for us like a
shepherd and as those who follow Christ
for a little while we've probably heard
a bit of that list before maybe you know
sometimes pray read
scripture worship God you're here today
uh you know I don't need to preach this
to you right
and yet keeping these ongoing practices
and staying in love with God isn't easy
I mean this isn't what Society is
valuing right now is us working on
staying in love with God other things
are at the
Forefront the truth is that staying in
love with God is a journey and in
different seasons we need different
things different practices to keep us in
deep relationship ship with God some may
use exercise or walking as a practice
others may have devotions and quiet as a
practice I find sitting on the beach is
really helpful as a spiritual practice
honestly um learning in a group together
is a good spiritual
practice and I think we need some
variety and be willing to kind of change
up our practices for different seasons
so that spiritually
we may continue to
grow and that we can continue to kind of
identify what are those what are those
things that really ground us that if
we're not doing them we can easily slip
into other things slip slip out of what
we understand as God's compassion for
us for me I know that if I'm not walking
and doing yoga
and I'm a huge extrovert so um I have to
discipline myself to have time by myself
or I forget that that's really like a
thing okay so if I'm not doing some kind
of meditation or quiet time I'm lost
right because I'm just out there kind of
a shell of my extra version okay so so
I've kind of over time said okay so
there's some things that like if I'm not
doing them I know that that I am going
to lose a sense of God's compassion in
my life for me it's also important that
I'm listening to music daily that gives
me joy that I'm reading something that
um is um at least fun if not you know
kind of inviting to my
soul so that I have some other outlets
other than my
work so it's a
journey trying to figure out what are
those practices that really ground us in
God's
compassion and speaking of grounding you
know about 10 years ago a New Journey
started for me I was in a place in my
life um in Ministry that nothing was
really going well I'm just going to be
real honest y'all may have had a job or
two like that I mean I it was there was
a lot of conflict going on I wasn't
really the cause of it but I'm the
pastor so I'm kind of responsible for it
and and I'm getting worn
out and kind of being lost spiritually
anybody felt that way a little bit and
and just over time I could feel myself
not not really understanding how God was
active in my life but also not being
able really to show so much compassion
to other people and so at the age of 40
I enlisted a spiritual
director um I heard that was a good idea
so I called somebody who was a coach and
a spiritual director and we started to
work together and she asked me a key
question she said what do you wake up in
the morning looking forward to and I'm
like it's a really bad
time like what I mean you know like I my
kids are good I love them um what she's
like what what really you know and I
said okay so I started drinking coffee
at the age of 40 because I felt tired my
mother always drink coffee in the
morning so I felt like my mother so it
felt a little old but I said okay so
like I love a cup of coffee in the
morning and she said we can work with
that and she said let's start there
what if you just spent two minutes
sitting
down and drinking a cup of
coffee and over time what we began to
build out was a spiritual practice that
involves five minutes with a cup of
coffee and what that evolved into is
like then I had to buy the chair that I
wanted to sit and bring my coffee in and
then I have some things around that I
can access that are that are good for me
to read or to you know and so out of
just a couple of
minutes and a very terrible life
situation
right I was able with the grace of God
and a coach and a lot of people around
me to say hey this cup of coffee is
worth
it is worth the spiritual practice of
Starting Over Again and over again and
over
again and so some of you look at me and
like okay like she's way into coffee and
I hate coffee it doesn't have to be
coffee coffee is not the point okay um
whether you like coffee or not not it's
just finding a
space a couple of minutes a day to say
what what is
it that
practice that's really grounding me
right now now that I can understand
God's
compassion in my life and build on that
and giving
compassion to
others a key to any
practice that we have in our faith in
following Christ um is that we need
accountability and for me that means a
lot of things for me it does mean a
group
that I get together with regularly a
group of other clergy women that we get
together once a month and have done so
for over 15 years it also means
listening to my spouse when He suggests
that I'm we doing it that's a hard
practice but it is good
accountability I also as a pastor I do I
have a spiritual director and a
counselor and we each need those those
folks on our
journey because God's designed us not to
do it
alone and then there's one more thing
it's in the ten commandments so I
thought I should me mention it about
staying in love with God it's this thing
called Sabbath man I hate that
word I'm the worst at it
y'all and yet I I over time especially
the last year I had three months off um
last year and so I started exploring
okay what is what could Sabbath really
look like for someone like
me it's probably not turning off my
phone for 24
hours but what what does it look like
and I think it's something to wrestle
with as a part of our faith together I
am super impressed by your July thing
here that you're doing like what a gift
to your leaders and what a gift to
yourselves to say we don't have to do
all the things all the time we can take
some time and know we're gonna we're
going to get back to all the other
things that's huge as a congregation you
need to you're teaching
me about about that so over time my
Sabbath practice has developed into I
can't do 24 hours without doing
anything but maybe I can do 24 hours
without doing my paid
work and what what does that look like
for me it's sometime between Friday and
Saturday and carving out that time where
I I don't do my paid work and I do
laundry
sometimes I do some family time I really
try to carve it out that it creates
something different inside of my life
that allows me to know God's
compassion so I think these
practices a rule of Life a way of life
that is intentional
about reing receiving God's
compassion plus God's grace can really
put us on this path in this life of
redemption long term I I like this
Phrase rules plus Grace equals
Redemption you gotta you got to put
rules in its
context um spiritual
life a spiritual way a spiritual rule of
life um I saw this phrase in a
curriculum that we're doing with our new
care team our church y'all pray for us
we we had two churches that just became
one in our congregation so we did a
merger we did it in 90 days I've had
vacation I feel better about it now um
um and um and I think you know one of
the things we've done has had to have
like new leaders and a new care team a
new way of doing things and so it was in
this curriculum and I think it's
important um rules plus Grace people's
Redemption I think embracing God's care
for us means caring for
ourselves through these practices and
accountability and ways that we
experience
rest that creates this
balance between work and
rest and work and rest and I think this
is
where God's love enters in
so staying in love with God means making
Jesus compassion real in our own lives
so we can authentically share compassion
with other people staying in love with
God means we rest and we pray like Jesus
did staying in love with God means we're
accountable to other
people and that we give
compassion to
others and this is what it means
to know the Shepherd that walks through
the darkest Valley and Comforts us this
is what it means to know that goodness
and mercy will follow us all the days of
our life and we will dwell with God
forever in the name of the one who loves
us and shows us great compassion
always amen
one of the other things we have in
common as Faith communities is Holy
Communion yall do this Weekly
right so does first year I'm at this
church
saxi and I think this
meal in this time that we share together
is one of those practices that really
forms
compassion within us and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to have a
blessing over this and then um we will
share together invite us to pray
together God as we are invited to share
together in this holy
meal we give you
thanks that Your Grace
overflows on
us in every
moment and I thank you that as we share
together we are bound
together as a community of
faith and we
remember how you created
us and how you care for
us and we remember how you sent Jesus to
us through your Holy
Spirit and we remember the night in
which Jesus gave himself up for
us and he took the bread and he gave it
to his
friends and he broke
it and he said this is my body which is
given for you do this in remembrance of
me and then after the
meal he took the
cup and again he he shared it with his
friends and said drink from this all of
you this is the cup of the New Covenant
in my
blood given for you do this as often as
you drink it in
remembrance of
me and so God we give thanks this day
that you invite us into this holy
time that you give compassion
regardless of our temporary
situations and that you love
us we thank you for your holy spirit
that is with us now and gives the real
presence of Christ even
today in Jesus
name
Amen in just a minute you're going to be
invited to come forward come toward the
middle
there will be servers to serve you um
just some reminders the red um liquid is
wine and the white um is grape juice and
the bread is
gluten-free come to the table of
compassion and Grace it's waiting for
you amen
[Music]
amen
we're going to wrap
up what oh there I am I tried to avoid
an awkward moment
but apparently that's my call calling in
life we're going to finish with a song
called Spirit move uh which is a really
really beautiful song and I I invite you
to actually to stay seated and to just
just experience it and see uh if God is
is leading you into anything I think
this is very complimentary to what you
were saying and what you're preaching
about because um the spiritual life is
quite hard in our current culture
and so taking a moment to sit and uh let
God speak to you in a new way is
important the spirit is moving
over the Waters of our
tears our bodies are
yearning for the joy of coming
years but the spirit turns our empty
groaning
into
prayer even now we wait in Hope For What
the spirit
Bears Spirit
move keep on
moving Spirit
moving creation is groaning
with the pain of giving
birth a new life is
coming resurrecting all the
earth when we don't know what to pray
the spirit groans for
us for the breaking of the day that it
lifts us from the
dust Spirit
move keep on
moving Spirit
[Music]
move keep on
moving oh Keep On Moving
so come Holy
Spirit to The Silence of our
hearts and sing out within us of the
promises of
God we are wey with the years but hope
is
being
born even through our pain and fear
we're waiting for the
[Music]
dawn Spirit
move keep on
moving Spirit
[Music]
moving oh keep keep on
moving oh keep on
[Music]
moving thank you uh Jesse Josh Pastor
Holly for for leading us through worship
and that message I don't know about
y'all but when these two guys sing
together it's just incredible I love it
that was
[Music]
amazing um if you're visitor I do
welcome you and encourage you to scan
the QR code that's going to be up on the
screen or you'll find some um welcome
cards on that table over there what that
does for us is it just allows us to
reach out to you see how we can be there
for you if we can be there in any way
for
you if you are in need of any sort of
prayer hug high five encouragement come
find me after the service I'm certain
other people will be here as well
welcoming that but if you need anything
of the sort just want to talk I'm here
to do that with you as
well so giving is and generosity excuse
me is a very key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship if you feel led to
give I encourage you to again scan that
code and it will bring you to the
prompts to do that or you can find out
how to do so simply just by going to the
taable tx.org and then lastly going to
send you all out with a
benediction feel free to receive this in
any sort of posture that you are
comfortable
with you are a child of God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with
hope you have a great evening and hope
we see you next
[Music]
week Spirit
move keep on
moving Spirit move
keep on
[Music]
moving Spirit
move keep on
moving oh Keep On Moving